en este vídeo lo que haremos será
estudiar uno de los principios básicos
en cálculo pues todo el tiempo estamos
utilizando derivadas de cualquier tipo
de función y a lo que me refiero con
esto es a la famosa llamada regla de la
cadena y primero quizás esto te suene un
poco desalentador o te parezca algo
complejo pero lo que yo espero es que
conforme vas avanzando en el vídeo o en
vídeos más adelante esto se te haga más
sencillo o lo ves de una forma más
intuitiva así que digamos que tenemos
una función hdx y sólo por este ejemplo
en este caso va a ser igual al seno
cuadrado de equis y bueno el seno
cuadrado de x es lo mismo que si lo
escribimos como aquí seno cuadrado de x
aquí estoy como elevando en conjunto la
función pero se me hace más fácil para
explicarte la derivada de esta forma
entonces lo que nos interesa saber es
cómo sería h prima de x así lo que
quiero saber es cómo será su derivada
otra forma de escribir la derivada de h
sería poniendo la derivada de h respecto
de xy estamos representando lo mismo
simplemente es otro tipo
de notación y es también para usar la
regla de la cadena y bien la regla de la
cadena lo que tratará de jugar es
interpretar que cada vez que tengamos
una función pero que ésta a su vez pueda
ser compuesta por más de dos funciones
vamos a utilizarla y quizás habitando
resulte obvio esto de la composición
porque como usted decía vamos empezando
pero vamos a hacer un pequeño
experimento por acá que es la derivada
de x de x cuadrada entonces esto va a
ser 2 x como él lo hemos visto varias
ocasiones y va a ser lo mismo que si
tenemos la derivada respecto de a de a
cuadrada simplemente estamos cambiando
la x por la entonces aquí también vamos
a tener 2 a a esto voy porque a lo que
quiero llegar y quizá se vea un poquito
más bizarro es que queremos encontrar la
derivada con respecto del seno de x así
es la derivada con respecto del seno de
x del seno de x al cuadrado y como tú
puedes ver es lo mismo que tenemos por
acá arriba pero estamos cambiando ahora
no es ney x ni aislada sino es el seno
de x y como puedes ver si aquí teníamos
la derivada
idea de cuadrada nos daba dos y luego la
derivada respecto de x x cuadrada de 2x
entonces aquí tendríamos dos veces el
seno de x entonces aquí lo que la regla
de la cadena nos está diciendo es que
esto va a ser igual aquí si tenemos por
acá arriba algo elevado al cuadrado algo
elevado al cuadrado lo voy a pintar por
aquí de color azul elevado al cuadrado y
en este caso ese algo es el seno de x
entonces lo que nosotros vamos a tener
acá abajo va a ser dos veces el seno de
x pero bueno como tú puedes apreciar
esta será la derivada de lo que estamos
poniendo en color azul que sería como
una función que se está elevando al
cuadrado ahora lo que nos faltaría
ponerle atención o ver qué es lo que
seguiría sería multiplicar por la
derivada de lo que está en el interior
pues eso es lo que hace la regla de la
cadena y aquí en este caso sería el la
derivada del seno de x entonces aquí les
voy a especificar de color verde que la
derivada respecto de x d el seno de x
como nosotros sabemos es el coseno de x
entonces aquí abajo
solamente la multiplicaríamos que se
halla entonces el 12 9 x de lo que está
elevada al cuadrado por la derivada del
interior la derivada del seno de x que
sería coste no de x y pues lo que
hicimos fue aplicar la regla de la
cadena esto es lo que hace y voy a hacer
un poco más clara por aquí abajo te voy
a poner con la otra anotación como sería
esto sea la derivada la derivada del
seno de x pero el seno de x al cuadrado
que es en sí toda nuestra función y lo
voy a separar en corchetes para que se
especifique y respecto del seno de x que
es la función por la que está compuesta
por la derivada la derivada del seno de
x la derivada del seno de x respecto de
x y espero que esto de verdad sea cada
vez más intuitivo algo que quiero
aclarar es que esto jamás se va a ver
como el producto de dos funciones sino
simplemente esto es notación y esto no
representa números está representa
representando la anotación no son
fracciones entonces por nada del mundo
y esto de la derivada del seno de x se
va a cancelar con la de acá arriba eso
no puede ser y aquí es donde deberíamos
de aplicar nuestra intuición puesto que
esto lo de aquí nos dejaría la derivada
la derivada de esto el seno de x
cuadrado con respecto de x pero sería
como llevar la derivada del seno de de x
cuadrado con respecto de x si observas
por acá arriba en la derivada de la
función h será lo que tenemos por acá
que voy a poner en amarillo pero no
concuerda no concuerda con lo que
estamos realizando y esto lo voy a ir
tratando más adelante con otros vídeos
porque no suena demasiado lógico como
podríamos desarrollar esto